you
hi everyone is cherry Aman chess calm
and I am playing a five-o game let's try
okay we'll go with thee six let's see
BOGO Indiana NIMS oh go go Indian Bishop
d2 negative alright I'm going to put up
on in the center and let's see if
they're going to go with this Queen a
four line no okay we're going to come
all the way back
and I guess they're going to go for a
kingside fianchetto no okay
castles rc5
let's just go with castles let's get
that in there no surprises and I'm going
to hold on that tension and just being
keto
see five at some point
b4 maybe first a five and then c5
could get pretty lively one thing you
have to be on the lookout for is this
Bishop if I go at c5 and there's a
capture on c5 he could be vulnerable to
a queen or maybe a rook one day yeah
case in point right here so I play a
five first a five there's B 5 and then
c6
now this pond is going to be pretty
annoying to my night I think I have to
go in for c5 right now pretty
symmetrical
so far
okay one take and a push so interesting
in balance
I wonder if I could play a six here
taking advantage of this of the fact
that they can't support b5 with a four
so we could get a pretty weird imbalance
two connected pastors and I could maybe
push with c4
let's see really sharp
Nadia not a defined structure here
probably at some point be saddled with
hanging pawns d5 c5 structure so takes
right now and then give this Bishop a
shove
to take once so I've increased my
control over the center just a little
bit more do I want to play this move
right now maybe I could yeah let's let's
let's not do that just yet how about
this move first preparing this and then
a capture if I did this and then plate
here there's 94 I don't want to give up
d4 so fast
this Knight could maybe jump into c5
a knight b3 I'm preparing to play clean
up okay that move
well this Knight can't do anything but
go to d7 so let's get them there even on
the clock this move I thought loses
material booth
should probably think that went over
here here there's a night to be three
move hitting my queen but even so I
think that this is good because it opens
up the c5 square
I could still try to get this in so
maybe Bishop to b4 yeah
this Knight to b3 ooh you know what I
could maybe go for really weird and
bounce c3 Knight b3 I take the bishop
they take my queen I take the rook and
then the knight two minor pieces and a
rook and they get a clean and upon
oh man
tough one to assess because they have
two connected pastors as well
I'd be getting there dark-squared bishop
boy that's a tough one to assess do I
have to go in for that I don't have to
go in for that but
hmm
that's really
think I'm going to try it
yeah this is going to get really weird I
have to play Knight to b3 now so here we
are
let's get that and let's see if I could
maybe uh convert this one the rook is
unprotected for one I have pretty decent
coordination my Knights are connected
both my bishops are unprotected I'm
going to be doubling up and maybe one
day threatening to take on b5 the queen
goes elsewhere the
I could manage a dark square blockade I
don't see how these guys get rolling so
fast okay let's start with this a knight
BTW i could take a four
I still need a flight square but I don't
know if now is really the time to go for
that I still need to connect rooks I
believe Knight c3 I take him out
you know flight square wise I think I'll
be going with g6 there at the two-minute
mark this game has flown right by let's
see
yeah really interesting and bounce I
think a knight on c4 would be pretty
good not sure with which path you should
choose to get there probably be six put
some more pressure on a four but you
know before I even commit the night I
think I want to get a flight square in
there and I with this Bishop bearing
down on my Kings side it's a g6 is the
better square they're really in the
think tank here yeah they really came to
a challenge my rook so easily
not sure how their Queen improves okay
let's start off with this g6 it is and
now their queen is ready to do something
over here let's uh let's go here stop
some entry points okay hmm I could take
the knight and then go here
I'm fine if the Queen takes the night I
don't really don't mine that are they
going to try and get a passport
I can always pitch one of my minor
pieces for it and then ready get some
more material so probably just get the
bishop here straight away
actually you know what I wonder if
there's a way to trap the Queen minute
50
Bishop c5
stop this I'm just going to drop all the
way back on this move I believe I have
this now that's not true
that's not true because they have rook
to be one okay now it's getting scary
now it's definitely getting scary but
wait a second okay rook here I dropped
my rook yam is played though maybe I
could start with this and then rook c5
next yeah this rook here so that this
doesn't hit with tempo it's pinned right
now they have to play rip e1 though have
this Queen b7 I'm always in a spot to
sack my knight for this pond so I could
take him out I'm prepared to give up my
knife for a passed pawn 40-second mark
queen doesn't have many options she has
to go here basically and maybe I could
even take here and then take and then
take the bishop at the ends that seems
simplest just don't complicate trining
mate now and I guess we'll go here tuck
my king out
is a check
trips controlling this guess we'll
insert a check and then get behind here
night here threatens this miss move I
don't think that they could play that
way there's clean there if I do that my
bishops attacked let's just hit him with
a check try and put a dent in their
structure over here it's getting down to
the wire
yikes
yeah can I we have a mate here might be
close to giving me not clay okay oh I
was a terrible mouse slip and there's no
take-backs either I think I would have
one on time evil with this somehow it
would have gone down to the wire but mmm
yeah one interesting came interesting in
bounce I probably had a drop minimum and
after this I could take and then play
here and I have everything coordinated
it would have been a rat race but yeah
what an interesting opening that one
turned out to be hmm I don't have too
much experience with that I've had
positions like that before where you
have a big majority in the center and
you give your opponent these connected
pastures on the queenside
it makes for an interesting game and I
think that this was one of them
eventually leading to that imbalance two
minor pieces and a brook versus a queen
and pawn okay let's dive right into the
analysis and see what more we can take
away from this one okay this is where I
want to be so let's see about this
opening
BOGO Indian defense it's calling it the
what night B - D - it's called the
Grunfeld variation it's news to me did
not know that that was the name anyhow I
put a pond in the center it's Queen a4
here didn't go with that line
I have no intention of giving up my
bishop for the night on a three here I
don't get anything for it no structural
damage and I pretty much can be assured
that the bishop has to deploy in this
direction or the night we'll have to
move again if he wants to come out along
this diagonal so I'm just helping white
out by taking the night on d2 so let's
get to something interesting here III
castles Bishop d3 b6 councils pretty
natural stuff and now b4 so this is a
big moment because if I don't play c5
here why play c5 and grab some space
well it's suggesting Knight B to d7 when
I do like about a 5 this is what it's
suggesting a5 b5 I just felt that this
is a bit too cramping to my knight I'm
going to work around this pond I mean it
happened in the game that there's a pond
here but things have things were changed
a bit more this pond was able to get all
the way up here and they didn't have a
deep on so yeah no no I want to go at c5
and make sure things were opened up in
my I didn't want to play with a lack of
space let's just so so chop this is
where things heat up let's see what
tactics right miss Tiffany should
they've held their ground here it
doesn't like b5 well it's not the top
move at least right now b5 and is a6 a
good reply yes so I did react well here
with a 6 so this changes the structure
again this is just not they're not able
to recapture it the pawn the rook was
defended that's a different story
suggest capturing on a6
so after Queen the e2 it takes b5 it
likes me by about upon here C takes and
now Knight B to d7 straight away c4 as
well
yeah you know the the train of thought
that I used in the game where I said
we'll where else is this night can I go
I should probably do that right now
what did i do i brought my queen out
because i had in my mind I wanted to
maybe win upon the computers okay with
this but I should apply that the
reasoning that I did in the game at this
very moment with my knight there's no
way to make this pawn flinch he's there
for good
if white wants to keep him there you
know at some point he could push but my
knight has no other choice but really to
go to d7 here so I should just get him
there right away and not give my
opponent so much information so quickly
with my queen okay Queen a5 it is and
now I went in for c4 yeah it's an
interesting position see shift there so
this is already yeah so I could go in
for this four sequence now does like c4
fish of c2 I guess it even wants to sit
capture maybe on c4 I guess that's an
option right maybe these guys get
rolling now the knight is supporting
their their advance hmm okay
your bishop c2 doesn't like c3 it's not
thinking about c3 here let's see I guess
it is a move does it in the end after
after c3 it does like that even better
probably have to give it some time to
think this one through
butt-ass it seems like as soon as I put
it on there it likes it
Sinai III then going in for the is very
line giving up the Queen C takes b2
Knight takes Queen pawn takes rip and
what's the evaluation on this again it's
a very difficult one to assess in a
blitz game it's giving me a little bit
more than upon somewhere around upon and
a half but yeah I should have been able
to convert this better
just one quick note is when that Queen
got active over here at c6 and I drop my
bishop back to f8 I probably should have
gone here to throw strike at the brook
and kind of observe the b-pawn observe
at least a promotion square from one of
these guys he played too much of a
passive role when I dropped him back to
f8 I didn't share that during the game
but it was running through my mind
rook after eight eight and yeah one more
to share with this one 'if I've okay now
that's something I did not consider
changing the structure
moving up the f5 square I feel like
there's a way you could still play
within the structure here
hmmm anything wrong with what I did in
g6 I guess I could still play e5 next
I'm getting the flight square and at
least preventing Knight f5 but I really
didn't have it in my mind at all to
change the structure Knight c5 it wants
to go it yes this is a pretty lame move
I give something up with Bishop d6
night see 5 LX night to e8 I played here
to cover this square 98 does that as
well
hmm it's a little bit tricky to
coordinate 96 does it like capturing I
take seems pretty intolerable on the c6
square clean takes and yeah I don't even
have a pond advantage now Bishop e7 Zeff
8 ok I guess f8 is still ok and now b6
things are getting critical now rook 8
to a6 root to be 8 minus 3
the idea here ripped it'd be a trip to
be one and then let's say Oh rook to c5
now and the difference is that the Queen
cannot move and throw a punch at my rook
I'm moving my rook to a square where
he's defended so here when I play rook
c5 my rook isn't defended on a6 okay so
that would have been a lot cleaner this
is a this is a winning advantage now
I've had I had I played rook to b8 up to
a6 how does it feel about that I guess
this is still good rook e1 rook c5 yeah
it likes Rick c5 and after Queen to b7
rook takes b6 that's what I did so this
is this is still a winning line that I
did in the game and I just had to play
this better 94 straight away oh you know
what a knight on e4 will support a
Bishop c5 and I call weighs sack my
bishop for the pawn and it would seem
that one of these pawns is going to fall
the f2 pond and in the end I would have
some good coordination if if one day you
know let's just say the bishops here
there's a check I go here and he just
continues to run I get this guy and
let's say this happens I have really
good coordination and probably be saying
that I'm still a little bit better here
you know
it's because of my pieces find good
squares and there's only the f2 pawn
that I have to worry about so I'm sure
there was something better but worst
case scenario I just wanted to highlight
that kind of a variation where I could
sack a minor piece for the pawn and get
one of these King side pawns so what
could I have done better
instead of Bishop c5 just jump into e4
and what does it consider best for white
right around here just wants to push and
then I guess we're scooping up the f2
phone yeah my knight doesn't even have
to budge and then yeah I probably do
this in the game Queen b8 and prepare to
give my bishop up for the pawn a 7 and
even suggest capturing here is there
some fancy made if they get to Queens
this is interesting so I could give a
check King h2 okay okay so the bishop
will eventually get on this diagonal and
I fork the King so on this there's a rip
check actually that's leading to mate
Derk f1 visibly one and night to f2 that
would have been a cool but the king from
this position after the discovered check
he could go to h2 and that's how you
pick up one of the Queen's and see two
pawns and night and rook good
coordination it's a black pulling for a
win but didn't play out like that I'm
just want to have a quick look at the
final position B for instead of the
mouse slip move would it have been a win
or a draw what's the story with that
final position I gave a check
and what now Knight to e4 incoming I
give a check yeah so this I almost made
that knight move I would have been
terrible 94 Queen to be 1 I lose my rook
and they still have their pawn so I'm
just breaking up their Kings side a
little bit
I just I guess I just want
guard this diagonal so I could play
Knight to e4 soon it still likes black
and maybe there was a mate after Queen
to b7 now now it's just equal so this is
where it turned instead of Knight to e4
what do I have to do rook check and
let's say King f1 what I do here I just
take the palm I could have captured the
pawn right here yeah pick up pick up the
phone right now he's free oh man
okay what's my excuse bill note uh okay
what about this final position check
this is winning with d4 Knight to f5 and
I guess this is just a draw if they were
recapturing an objective objectively a
draw but who knows how this would have
finished if they captured I probably
would have done this and played here
easier for black to play and very easy
fortress as well good coordination but
had that little mouse slip at the end
but an interesting game here under the
BOGO Indian groom field variation weird
and balanced in this one anyhow feel
free as usual to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care
you